what's Monday guichen hey what wise I
don't know man why'd you go bad a legit
energy dude you don't I feel like his
energy is okay are you is your energy a
little low you look like you got some
Sun do i yeah a little darker maybe I
don't know just a little red I'm always
red though right my face cats way darker
than chin yeah
cats darker than chin is that our racist
term if I soldiers cat know it she's a
jungle Asian well faithful Vietnam other
people think it's racist I love the term
because there's a big difference between
Southeast Asians and then like the
fancier agents like chin like chin
slightly fancier agents jazz fans well
he's from a northern more northern
latitude yeah so it gets super cold in
Vietnam it is jungle dojin's a little
Snow Leopard you're a little tomcat well
no you know what is she what kind of
shape she's from Vietnam Vietnam they
have the old Panther that's not true
they have the old logger that's not true
there tiger
yeah they got the tiger Tigers in the
Philippines doing okay now hold on a sec
I was talking about Vietnam oh yes yes
yes means yeah the philippine tiger yes
right if there is something called the
Tigers of yet the jungles Vietnam are
being pretty much decimated by poachers
and hunters but over got Tigers credibly
eco diverse mmm-hmm and they got some
tigress there's some tequila egos got
some tigress
I've been doing man I'm good are you
good I'm just a man yeah I would say I
feel like haven't seen you for a while
I feel like we might see each other till
Monday it's crazy I was thinking about
that too we text but you know you've
been in New York I don't want to get in
New York I was in Utah playing golf with
my power back to Utah went back for a
day to play golf with my paw and that
was far too papa papa yep yep yep and
then and then I came back nothing too
eventful to talk about there although
Park City is a beautiful little town I'm
in I'm in Salt Lake
first week of October second week
October yeah we talked about this wise
guys you guys see Papa Kalam come there
slap the [ __ ] up if I'm not sure damn a
slap him around slapping the golf course
why you should play golf with him
although it'll be October
actually there's golf right then then
are you a golfer I can golf yeah I mean
I'll send that ball for I'll send that
ball and that's it though and I'll have
a good like yeah well no here's hiring
my iron game every now and then was like
damn look at that out of the most parts
like Jesus Christ and then when I say I
lose all the balls I mean if you give me
balls and lose all of them don't give me
your good ones and now I'm gonna ask you
for your borrow balls and your teeth and
then I'm gonna leave my putter on the
green all the time and forget irons
first but I like I like to get there's a
lot like to sip on the beers and like to
drive the cart yeah I'll be a little
golf chick are they called golf groupies
I don't know I don't think there aren't
no that well there are some my buddy
would Tiger Woods [ __ ] all the golf he
did are they called Dolphy's week Mahalo
they call them long balls they do what
do they call him I don't know putter Tom
holes no Tom putter someone leaked on
putt putt horse the putt horse but how
much part of ours is better
really calm the bloody golf groupies
well i-i'll get on the green I'll get on
the green and a respectable number of
strokes and then I'll for putt and then
I just my putting is [ __ ] you know who I
talk to you too I got before the caddie
I was with my boy Cameron booth who
plays from a plane bro yeah he's he's
caddied for four presidents I'll go
through them and then I'm asked you a
trivia well I'm gonna ask you a
multiple-choice question
oh yeah so he caddy for Bill Clinton
okay George W Bush Burnham Barack Obama
okay and Donald Trump okay of all those
guys who is the largest in stature
number one Trump yep who is the best
golfer but by far out of those guys
those guys Trump Trump is the best offer
and then Obama the Obama cross your ass
up though in this guy's and they said
guys not political but but who
was the most generous and who was the
most personable what color who was the
friendliest what ethnicities he my boys
white now Chomp what else you got that
any other stupid questions that's right
who is these black boys difference
always the most standoffish Bush mister
mister Obama but that might have just
been cuz he's kind of a staid guy yeah
but on a golf course he's probably
exhausted trying some some free time
yeah and this old caddies chat okay he's
a playing pro so what he'll do is he'll
he'll Clinton was like teach me he'll
teach you and he'll he'll change your
game yeah on yeah he's one of those guys
go just put your elbow and show you a
few simple [ __ ] Nelson you see there to
help Obama they'll all ask him when you
have a guy like that who's not just a
caddy one sometimes bro you ask him
question you don't look like an ass and
not like that he'll go like this he'll
say just do me a favor because I don't
know why I don't know why you're trying
to hit in the trees did you want to hit
on the fairway yeah it just bring your
foot over here and then when you putt
putt he'll say I want you to put over
here you go I know but the holes a
little bit I know just put over there
and then you know he does that and you
want that for just golf better with a
guy like that and he's really funny
sounds like he's old Trump fan he's not
he's not he hasn't he's like is the old
Trump I'm not a political fella not a
put I almost had a hole-in-one that's
always nice almost it's always weird
when people film it yeah yeah if I get a
whole one on a golf course it's pure
luck so it's all luck
yeah I've been bit in forever let's not
like golf was that Tim Tebow's event
here's my favorite he said to me give me
a comment he goes honestly dude you're
you have a natural swing and if I get
with my Hellmann's here we go because
I've you know three months out get you
down to a ten handicap up well he knew I
couldn't yeah he's not getting pretty
bad like you look to ask me what I'm
doing
no I don't ask me the same thing what
your tennis coach does well I'm doing
you milk it okay this is what your
boxing coach does - that's what I'm
doing
you look like you're milking something
mm-hmm Malkin Malkin
you know what's below yeah Callens money
so know what's up top yeah your stupid
fat balls I'm milking your [ __ ]
wrinkly ball you're milking my balls yep
so he drives me to the airport he's got
nothing to do on Sunday of course not I
look at him I say so you get me down to
a 10 handicap
and you guys dude you you you're
athletic you can do it you're you you
have good body awareness I said yeah
okay I said ten handicap I'm like oh and
how I want to take me is because you
work with me for I don't know three
months four months I go mmm good I go I
shot a hundred let's say right
I said now is that counting now ten
handicap is that counting where we count
every single stroke and I get no
Mulligan's no no we're playing by
different no no
I'm talking about tournament play and I
want to be able to do it on a consistent
basis he goes oh I go yeah oh you meant
just once I go yeah hey guys I mean yeah
I mean and I went you're talking to me
now I love Jesus yeah yeah it would take
you every day why would you want to do
that exactly some people obsess over
girl from Michigan New York dude I want
to hear hot it's your old stomping
grounds yeah you were working the whole
time working the entire time set for
Friday because you wanted to join cat
faceook ladies do this my favorite
restaurant a minute a Greek restaurant
ha I think it's on 2nd Avenue and 13th
our first having you in 30 not like
there's an The Four Tops off Fifth Ave
Cafe so I got people talk about New York
Fifth Ave I was off fifth took the 6/7
jump on the train got it you know I'm
saying yeah you were dying to go to
cafes to quite East I know I had no time
though dude I was at the shooting that
Bravo's show and I was saying you know
with with Jerry O'Connell I've never
worked with him I know he's done some
movies but he's always been around the
business forever been around for a long
time after everyone else he is we go to
lunch or once fricking stop and take
pictures I'm like alright and then we
got on set and the old Jerry O'Connell
talent came out that [ __ ] is so
funny witty and quick without like all
this is why he's been in the business
for twice been around a long time just
cuz you could look he's eating a lot of
good-looking guys he's also way better
looking at me he looks young man I was
against you know he's talking like
goddamn anyways old is he
my age no a little younger forty
something okay Wow 43 I think alright
you know me Joe wheeler Howell 44 there
you go only 44 a lot younger than me but
dude a lot younger yeah the top like you
like I get you know I'm like I like in
it and then Andy Cohen was in there and
did his thing like I like it and then we
had a
their special guest pews guests can't
say her name you would know where I
think I'd text you who it was no no I'm
like oh that's why she's been so success
every time there's no luck no ever take
it on and you literally just give him a
few notes and then there's no book every
time and I'm like oh that did you win
and oh oh and by the way I've never been
had one more thing they're always super
easy to work with they're always great
people like they just like like Josh
Duhamel Josh Duhamel is a great looking
guy but Josh Duhamel never stopped
working he's also just a good guy and
and and smart and talented this CJ was I
mean doesn't surprise mark witty and
then literally like the life of the room
everywhere we went was just like really
I'm just so talented well when he came
backstage after we had done our stand-up
you so nice he's so nice he's at that so
ego sauce dudes so great to meet your
team like with Brian and Brogan it's
like those guys are so nice man and when
we got done after the second show I mean
I'm telling he's destroying in the
writers room there's a comedic writer
who's worked on some huge Tommy shows
and knows all these stand-up guys and I
go dude have you ever done stand-up he
was I tried it once he's I tried it once
when I was like 19 I was in Boston and
there were two gentlemen one was
well-known the other was just starting
you might you might have heard of him
the headliner was Dave Attell and the
young guy was Dave Chappelle and they
went on before man thought this probably
isn't for me and then I just went back
and studied some other stuff that's a
bad group of people to comparison he's
hilarious man
oh yeah that's right monsters well the
so the woman who wrote this episode of
the Kohlberg's and I'm reading it and
it's [ __ ] hilarious lines I'm like
she's so funny
and she's back there with the director
and a producer and coming up with
alternative lines I go um what else have
you written on she was like Modern
Family every the family guy I was like
oh oh Simpsons I'm like oh that's we oh
you're one of those okay yeah it's a lot
of shows man I've never been more
excited for this one is that right
really I know that that was a good
decision that I know cuz you're on the
fence line though and made the choice
it's all about who you work with dude
it's all about Explorer 13 now and plus
your guys it's you Michael yo and
Jericho
homes Dave homes MTV Veejay I don't know
all those different like during the
heyday of like so is it ditch dudes
talking about its Bravo's version of
like the view basically it's like do I
love Dave I don't date yeah great I've
worked with Dave he's the head writer
for vanity now I'm the head writer for
vanity I think I'm not working that's
why I think that's why he looks like
somebody sorry yeah okay all right so
it's just a bunch of dudes talking about
pop culture Bravo's shows man then that
we have a female Bravo show table shows
so you have to watch the bra version
which I do anyways yeah you do just
hilarious
you watch all the Housewives show that
[ __ ] housewives Shahs of Sunset
so you guys married a Madison anything
the recap everything and then talked
about all the [ __ ] and then we have the
guest we have the some of the women on
who are on the shows we have some other
big-name like celebrities who are also
into the shows come on big guest great
they have an e-coat we I don't Andy
Cohen on who you know I'll see mr. Bravo
wow yeah that's pretty cool man who's
going in but uh yeah we're adding on
something and did the Showtime stuff and
then out Friday night hat off right at
off I said you know what I'm gonna go
see a show you had a choice that choice
and I text you I went shy go see Bruce
Springsteen Springsteen for me all day
or again I know Hamilton and then go to
Hamilton oh and you were front row yeah
well I personally loved it you see
you've seen Hamilton I've seen him see
New Yorker out here out here I know I
know
what did you think first of all how
about know what your experience was I
don't know I don't know I don't know the
second-ranked show you saw it here yeah
we want to saw him Broadway sonna
Broadway in New York New York by myself
people would say that those people can
sing oh my god can I say talented
dancers there goes a rap yeah yeah now I
know the music rap well so if you don't
know what to expect it might be a little
difficult to follow at first I've heard
like the first ten I was like what the
[ __ ] but then you get into the river
and all that it's all music it's
actually no book there's no like usually
musicals have a story and they're acting
it's basically there's all if you listen
to the soundtrack you know the music
yeah that's all it is
I like feet or better musicals but I
figured I have to go see Hamilton yeah
so what do you think is amazing I like
everything that goes into it but I was
telling chin like I'm more into the way
it works like how they got there the the
auditions how they link up the the music
the sympathy sympathy below yeah
symphony below all them to the actors
like all that like I'm worried about
like the production yeah like that's
what I want to see the behind the scenes
stuff and then usually in musicals you
have somebody who writes the story yeah
and then you have somebody who writes
the music yes and then they go and so
the book is called the book is the story
so that book is the story the characters
but I think lin-manuel Miranda I think
that's his name won all the awards he
wrote he wrote all of it it's all his
and he also wrote a great I think was a
Tony nominated thing called the heights
he is an apostle wrote mallanna which
you want Award for yeah he's phenomenal
well kkona tional treasure in the words
of jimmy kimmel so I don't know if you
know this and it would be nice if when
you gave me a heads up when I told you I
got a ticket to Hamilton so after about
an hour and change hour and a half
oh my god man this is coolest this is
really cool and it won't start
applauding and lights turn dark and then
they get bright and I'm like what's
going on it's over now that's cool
that's perfect time starving I'm glad
it's over and they got actually goes no
oh no that's just intermission here we
go back it's probably another Tyler
probably go for another two hours went
two hours he goes yeah alright so I went
around like was just rest my legs I'm
like I am starving I am so hungry
kind of got my fill you know I've kind
of seen all but I don't it's whatever I
know he dies in the end spoiler like
Jenna gets shot so I was like you know I
didn't do this to Table ten this is
embarrassing plus I got the front notice
me you know so I'm like I don't want to
be be can't walk out of Hamilton so I
sat down and started up getting this fat
guy starts seeing it yeah
I'm really tired you know I'm gonna
leave I walked out as I'm leaving the
guy working us you [ __ ] me shop you be
the first guys walked out I've never
seen you on walked on it dude I'm so
tired and hungry Gus
all right man I just kept going you
couldn't take it you walked out on him
with that
yeah the mystery was gone okay well it
was late bro else we existed there is a
Springsteen yeah you should have gone to
Springsteen because you can always see
Hamilton but I know don't have the
attention span no I do but out but
you've done all three hours yeah let me
ask you this great best musicals ever
yeah for sure got it hey name anything
you wanna do on this planet for three
hours besides sleep go name one thing
eat ice cream nope yeah have sex sure
[ __ ] not nope yeah play football
nope yeah I wanna watch UFC for three I
suppose I watch baseball
no no I don't want you to pop off with
your hours you like to jog for three
hours for three hours sometimes
sometimes no long I've got a mouth get
out - I'm gonna break it out what else
you got
names everybody but y'all yeah I love my
car it's the famous car that I want to
drive for three hours you fish right too
long three hours I'm good after now what
else golf golf coffee nope way too long
three hours of golf first hour we got 18
18 at home you got it bro left with one
you don't you just you've done it at
that point three hours no long that is
but I think that's why she doesn't get
strong in the end United no they've seen
stuff then dance and I pay that's worth
and then Hamilton like does this thing
and the flyer off the wall off fire I
don't like the way you're doing this
right now
oh that's some effort I know and I
appreciate that from the first hour and
a half but you walked out I had to
apologize hell I I loved it I would go
bad on you in a big way but I I hate to
say that I do understand I thought it
was two hours and I was like dude I'm so
tired
I understand like my thing was I was
like dude I've been working on I'm so
tired I want to get wrestling at an
early flight I'm like but Hamilton and I
was like it's eight o'clock show I'll be
in bed by 10:30
this isn't a prom and then 9:30 rolls
I'm like this is intermission
rooo another two hours that ain't
happening I'm so so the thing is that I
understand that like I've been to
concerts and I'm a huge Springsteen fan
but even with a Springsteen concert I'm
like he's gonna sing these
songs that I've heard a lot I've seen
him for now what's the initial like yeah
this will glamour wears out I can go to
my car and listen to it like oh right
yeah there it is
and now the only thing I'm getting is a
lot of other people going woo with me
and that that's not me and I'm not a
robot guy so and I have been in musicals
see plays plays are different well he's
really into it I see what happens in the
end yeah like did you just have a story
there's certain songs that know I know
the story but there's there's like
there's certain plays while getting the
characters whether there's certain
movies where I'm after two hours like
[ __ ] house there's more yes like if you
watch the narcos or Game of Thrones like
dude I wish this was seven hours yes but
even after about three I'm like dude I
need a break
yes three hours is a very long those
seats are small especially in Hamilton
when it's all songs and if you haven't
been hipped to the story which is
excusable because it's American history
and so it's like how many how much can
you be I looked up a bunch of ham stuff
where I went in so I want to know a
little bit I know the story it's just a
basketball you when you first see like
guys are like why with the monster
trucks the other day with my son I'm
like holy [ __ ] look at these trucks it's
like it's [ __ ] this is cool man
after I'm like look at those trucks
right it's allmusic's that's that's
that's it's all music right so so after
a while you're like you know I need how
come homeboys not in every show for god
sakes like give me the a-lister what are
we doing it I paid well because he did
it for so long and then you have to move
on man I said that's a lot of work every
let go loved when eight shows a week now
he's doing that eight shows all I know
okay
three hours and he's on stage dude they
were sweating their tails oh yeah your
singing and your dancing no it's amazing
man yeah oh it's one of the best ever
but I do understand then you'll see a
play so you got to go to New York and
see the great place for the play we went
to it was freaking a big-time play but
it's super depressing
was it the humans yes we're that way you
and I both got done I was a god I felt
like they could've ended a little
different
mm-hmm I love them though I love place I
I miss going in New York and doing that
I'm gonna be in New York next week and I
don't know if I have any time next we
could be in New York yeah I'll be down
Wednesday during the day I get there
Wednesday morning then I shoot at night
and that's right at night for uh so I
need to be there for I leave Thursday
morning for Chicago Wow you're traveling
a lot
you live in my life I mean I mean I know
that yeah you know you're not a big
traveler you don't like traveling much
but New York City is pretty amazing
Bravo treats you right right oh yeah New
York it's a lot of work right it's a lot
you don't like getting into the short
flight you know Isaac's out like that
you don't like that six-hour flight and
then the hour into the city you don't
like that it looks a handful in it yeah
and then and then where do you want to
go in New York right now where how long
where do you want to go a mile probably
people live there and like I'll kill the
park every morning to watch the kids
which is a little weird I watch the kids
play and drink my coffee and party
Monsieur don't you miss you honey I'll
just stay in the park and drink coffee
every morning and I would watch people
the hustle because the train would get
off there there's a exit for the train
and they come up from the ground like
ants and then you pass through the park
I just watch him every morning going
back and forth like how the [ __ ] did
they do this and raise kids and that's
what they're not savable of it as a
lover children but people do they grow
up in the city I know people who have
it's you grow up fast
great food yeah the best you know what
though it's also a young person city
when you're single and your yard but
that's also change tip you like moving
non-stop always you just do I would like
that I was young no man you wouldn't
have no we also grew up you know in
Agoura that's more country and expanse
space your your eye when you're in
Colorado your eye when you see mountains
and stuff that's very soothing to the
eye and when you're in New York City
it's vertical it's overwhelming you're
just you're in you're surrounded by
walls
it was toasty in there oh they did
they've tried summertime in August early
toast yeah it's toast yes it was hotter
there that was in LA yes human
humid Jerry grew up there where we're
filming music I grew up three blocks up
there he grew up in Manhattan yeah I
didn't know that
he said he grew up three blocks from
here what did his parents do I forget I
think it says on Wikipedia nothing crazy
he's got a brother brother than his wife
is uh reprimand Becca romaine they have
two kids Wow doesn't Calabasas looking
kids talk kids I'm sure tall majestic
children he got a part that we had
audition and Jason Bateman was directing
and and he got the part
Jason came down and goes it's not gonna
happen I went you so cool a kidnap art
now you guys not gonna happen I go what
happened he goes Steve McPherson just
wants Prince Charming going with Jerry
O'Connell Jerry didn't even have to
audition I was like okay last one
episode but still still he's a beast
yeah see you tell Jerry enough to take
my parts anymore I'll see what I can do
what was the last movie he was in that
was like there was a movie he did was it
Stand By Me the last movie nobody was
right yeah yeah it was like chubby kid
in there Emlyn acting forever here's the
fat chubby kid Annette yes that's why
was it was amazing to see him like thin
and good-looking afterwards yeah he
stopped doing movies as much he writes a
shitload like he was on billions he was
yeah Steven birch yeah that's great your
stuff works he's a work he's a working
actor writes a lot of stuff working
actor yeah I think that's only the act
and stuff but he does a shitload of
producing and writing yeah big-time
stuff yeah I didn't eat that stuff yeah
Wow
that's who he's been doing lately good
for him and then you and then remember
it's down to him or Ryan Seacrest for
the host of Kelly and Regis oh really
down to him and uh secrets they won't
seek well he was killed in on that show
and when I was here Kelly
talented [ __ ] dude man how many ups
he's just like just was we shot three
last week and how many are you gonna
shoot all together we'll see how these
three go
I got you I know how that is see how
these threes go and then oh there it is
play-by-play you see one of the
producers yep Oh executive I am Andy
Cohen and michael davies power power
three make some money Davies is the guy
you had a meeting with a long time ago
right local Davies genius
yeah he is big big baller sorry boy and
just see some people can just they got a
crystal ball they can just see [ __ ] and
make it happen
I love that michael davies he did who
wants to be a millionaire he's done a
shitload of shows I love that was the
was he a soldier or some kind I don't
think so hmm
English feller he's ahead of Embassy Row
was he not I know there's another guy
who's like no that's the guy who starts
Survivor
God created survivor was in the SAS or
something you're just yeah not him not
Davies hmm
you got next week's shooting uh Batman
no it's the Joker
it's I'm not allowed to say but it's a
movie I can say anything yeah a little
comment I made I'm you can say runs with
a moving bokor I'm not saying anything
oh you're the movie that rides with
bokor I don't know it's no I'm doing a
movie called um it's called something
like Charlemagne or something I never
oh no you said it your business and
brokeback no I'm doing I'm doing
Brokeback to City with Sasha slickers
Sasha Baron Cohen called city slicker I
have to make out with him and love him
it's called could you do that I know
you're gay but you you could you uh
could you do Brokeback Mountain
I mean if dude you know I was watching
you have to be in love with Moses I was
watching all on El Chapo the the
Secretary of Defense is a gay man and
they show him just making out with these
young boys huh and Johanna goes
Secretary of Defense in El Chapo's El
Chapo in the series on Netflix story he
was actually a gay man but he was quite
a hidden lover Phil yeah really but I
love when bad guys are gay it's
fantastic yeah so makes him super
naughty so he was gay he's gay and he's
dating this young feller and they show
him like always like making out stuff
and Joanna goes hey what happens if like
David Ayer someone asks you do a movie
and but they want you to make out with a
dude oh my god I be struggle for me man
or at work or it'd be a dream come true
for me it would be a snob you ever done
that I I did it with Jimmy Burke horse
way yeah I'm not comfortable with making
out with a guy yeah but jeez it's not my
thing and then how many plays to him
every time did you do it no I mean no
but like more than six
well we dated but I mean no but men
Jimmy make that made out we did it
comedy his comedy was really funny like
killed it was like he was a bike racer
who fell down
and he like [ __ ] and I was like
you know and then your body you do pump
you know hey lemme buy you look like
hearing [ __ ] I'm not ashamed I take my
shirt off
Jesus dude you get you know and then and
we getting this thing and then we just
start making out but the whole [ __ ]
place would go crazy it was a sketch we
did it was that it was so much fun but
because it was the last thing you would
expect but I have to say that if I had
to do a TV show a movie where I had to
make out of the car like Gary Oldman and
prick up your ears you ever seen yeah
well he's he is Bob slapping with look
it's oh so look at bring bring this up
do you so well they say yeah it's a
ledger that's look at see that guy right
there so that's key okay see that guy
that's Alfred Molina an amazing actor
nothing less attractive guy they make
out so hard they just really is Daniel
day-lewis in my beautiful laundrette
well you just gotta say [ __ ] it and go
for it you do I'm just not that caliber
of actor and I'm not trying to pay until
Brian six months now use some sea level
offer and you just uh yeah I mean yeah
yeah but but they're in love I mean Gary
Owens a was your other
would you rather do that or softcore
porn I'm like in a movie you don't say
like girls no with a dude but but
there's no making out you just gotta
pretend he's real instead I could I
could try hump way faster on can't
really make out like Louis does some
[ __ ] kissing and my beautiful
laundrette and it's a movie in it first
year like I was with my friend who and
he's kind of a like tough guy and we're
watching this this movie and all of a
sudden Daniel day-lewis turns around and
walks toward the guy and they started
making how's my buddy goes hey what uh
yes you this is in the 80s we didn't
know he goes hey what comes running in
they start kissing and my buddy goes
wait wait
what what why didn't they tell me I
wanna tell me they say I don't want to
watch fist he was so he felt so duped
that they snuck it in on him he goes
wait Wow they're same for bro crack man
bring up my beautiful like Fletcher was
kissing scene they're saying like Heath
Ledger and uh oh it's other homeboy in
that movies with my favorite actors Oh
Jake Gyllenhaal he's so good he said
they offered to a lot of guys a lot of
other people wanted like they offer the
role and they turned it down believe it
they couldn't kiss with the dudes yeah
you gotta admit you gotta be too in love
I don't for me yeah go ahead and give me
a but I guarantee you say the YouTube if
they came out to xyq a dude
we want to catch this the lead role in
the new Joker movie but you got to make
out with the Riddler like hardcore you'd
like yeah my what do I sign where's the
dotted line where's the [ __ ] dotted
line listen we want make you the new
Joker you're the headline beautiful
wanderer but you gotta suck off the
Riddler this scene so we're watching
this movie and it's so far it's kind of
normal we're like what the [ __ ] is gone
turn us up what are people like
launderettes because they're like
toilets this could be a Ritz a long long
Greg
Daniel day-lewis the biggest the rates
oh yes your friends like what I guess
wait what's he doing
huh [ __ ] yeah
so then back by the way how times have
changed
back then in 1963 when I was watching
this [ __ ] that was like we were like
what it's a movie with guys was
interesting
times have changed times have changed
times have changed my shin what'd you do
this weekend dude three of times have
changed
I always forget whenever you ask me man
I saw the fights because you were on
your on your on horse tranquilizer not
completely GSB or whatever it is so I
didn't GHB bro yes GSP you're on GSP so
I watched the fights in LA I don't wanna
say what place it was because I don't
know if it's something it's gonna get me
in trouble or not but I was I was
watching the watch okay did they
illegally stream him nah we paid so why
would you get in trouble so I was
waiting for my uber outside all right
and my friends took off cuz they're
gonna go home so I was just gonna move
back to my place sure and then the uber
showed up late and then he also showed
up across the street he's a busy street
and like two ways of traffic okay is he
not a big deal so then I was waiting for
a while and then I'm like why you over
there anyways like five minutes later
still waiting for traffic to pass by I
see someone walking across the street
right next to me and you got hit by a
car oh right
literally right in front of me so no
scream for the car to stop hold the [ __ ]
on when I go what did you do to me oh
god I forget oh that's right I watched a
man die we didn't die what he didn't die
so it was some random homeless dude got
rekt what can some homeless students LA
they just walk at it go they think it's
like they want it's a death wish right
yeah so he got what he wanted here
they're just in a different world
yeah sure
to get her so this is what's crazy about
it the cars were going about like I
don't know 40 miles per hour whatever so
when the cars when the car saw him at
the very end he saw a maybe hit the
brake so it probably slowed it down to
about 20 miles per hour not terrible and
then he hit the guy that got flu and a
really car hit the windshield no the car
stopped after he hit him cuz skidded and
then he just fluid this way so I was far
I'm off from my left all the way to my
right Jesus Christ and then I was just
like oh my god I can't believe it's
happening so I made the car stop and
pull over
we like oh my god that's good me or no
yeah no but uh so I made the pull over
it was an old Asian couple right so the
old dude was driving the old lady got
out of the car in the passenger seat
from the passenger seat and then we
turned over turn around the homeless guy
just took off yeah the relentless bro he
just took off so he was able to walk and
say something to me like gibberish and I
go are you okay and he just took off
yeah no injuries or nothing my injuries
I'm sure he has broken bones yeah figure
it out though did uh it was the car
[ __ ] up what kind of car was it
Mercedes truck g-wagen those don't give
there's no older drugs those ones made
of nerf Kylie just bounced off god I was
like [ __ ] it but wait the place where
you watch the you have UFC event at you
can't see the name I guess I could it's
a beer garden some fans of the show were
there too so they say what's up so so
I'm confused what was your what was
pretty pissed off of my uber driver for
parking across the way alright cuz I
said Park me pick me up over this
location I get an address
yeah so he waited on the other side just
asking me to cross so I was really upset
about that and of course I got to
witness a freaking car accident cuz of
that yeah I could have also got hurt too
and why are you mad at the the place how
about know the guy that was driving okay
pull around make a u-turn and go to our
mat we could just run your ass over the
street I had to do it afterwards after
that accident
all the cars stopped then I was finally
my time to go home Wow so I left but
there's like 20 other people there that
witnessed it so but did you but the
reason you I want to say where you're
watching the fights cuz you think
they're illegally streaming no no I'm
thinking since I left the scene even
though
Oh yep you were an eyewitness runs away
he's okay yes he doesn't there's nothing
let's say you're fine
who's the no one else was injured and
the car was fine the car was dented
obviously that's done them dent in the
car and walked away gank the guy I think
he's just on drugs or something cuz any
person would have not robbers yeah you'd
be surprised what bumps can go through
just sound like something by the way
hobos are a rugged lot they're they're
pretty resilient you'd be surprised
I mean our winners of Denver are horse
runs in Denver and killing if he's
surprised but bombs they are tough
though yeah they're tough is farter
dance the first times in hit by a
[ __ ] card there's not store outdoors
who'd you watch the fight search in a
few friends and it's better UFC fans
they are us defense I only saw the title
fighter
did you illegally stream it no they've
got a broken that's what kids are going
to is the one hip thing you do that
weird thing I never steal a little iPad
I I got my pay-per-view I let me show
you and you think I have you decide not
to watch any other fights just a minute
but I just didn't have time I have not
saw you when you you two when when you
when you pay-per-view you can't record
it so I paid the sixtieth live yeah and
then it just goes away so I only got one
let's let people leave and the reason is
I thought yeah at first of all I thought
the fight was gonna they started earlier
I was in Utah so will they start later
whatever was I had to I had to buy a
really quick that I could really saw
like though bein event yes so that was a
surprising surprising and maybe because
I've never given tyron woodley his do I
know that's what I said
I never given him his daughter I know
and maybe I haven't given that his due
and how intelligent he is obviously we
know he's a great athlete and the first
time I met Tyron I was with Eve Edwards
and he came to the Improv to watch my
stand-up and I was struck but he was
working at top American Top Team nobody
knew he was and our
remember he looked like a 55 or he was
short like he's not tall he's probably
what five nine major yeah and so every
time I think about tyrant will be
finding a really tall guy like Darren
tell I think to myself he's too short he
gets it done he's got the same reach
which I was very surprised by and and he
gets it done but that punch to knock him
down with that pun anything right yeah
he does that a lot he steps back and
then he that's kind of what he did right
yeah it looks good man
he looked [ __ ] great is it fair to
say that in that Darren till got caught
in the Darcy and that people had more
experience would not have is that an in
I don't think so I think is I think till
thought he was gonna be able to get warm
up he's gonna give till the first few or
give Woodley the first few rounds feel
him out and then go to his game plan
pick him apart that maybe gas out
remember to Woody's not known for his
grappling so you when you down there and
you have underhooks you probably not
thinking that oh he's mission are there
he hasn't submitted anybody since the
price in Strikeforce yeah old school so
he's never submitted anyone's you know
yeah he's never submitted anyone in the
UFC
you remember he's rocked so that there's
gonna be a little bit of brain trauma
you're a little bit out of it you kind
of coming to you have an underhook this
guy's not known for submissions just
trying to stand up and they sink that in
it's just so sneaky to once it's in it's
over so I don't think it was a matter of
too much too soon for till I thought I
thought it's a matter of Woodley being
better that night I think tills gonna be
champions just a matter of time and I
think woodleigh's highly highly
underrated and we listen to the
narrative that Dana White paints that
he's a boring not a very good fighter
and we all [ __ ] up including myself
yeah and he's a phenomenal fighter he's
one of the greatest of all time if he's
at least top three there's Matt Hughes
George st. Pierre than Woodley hmm and I
think we're all doing a disservice by
not appreciating him you know I think
we're list we're letting Dana white
paint in air which is insane what did
Dana White say after the fight didn't he
say so said you know he looks he looks
he looks like he looks great
he has not got powned both hands but
when he opens his mouth he shoots
himself in the foot no one likes him you
don't have any fans just isn't true why
would you sell that product down the
road yeah I went out an hour rent on
this on my show you did yes what um yeah
I'd rather make out with you then go
over it again another yes you like
Daniel yeah but I didn't suck your teeth
I'm just gonna suck your teeth aren't
even crooked anymore let me ask you this
before we can't move on cuz I'm curious
he's gonna fight Coffee Carrington Coby
Compton probably yeah I'd be annexed
warm end of the year I think I did I
think Dana said how long he's out we
have a fight I think they posted he I
think he's out till a while no not cold
we Kobe's ready to go I think it's
Woodley Kobe did Woodley didn't get hurt
though I didn't have any land on me no
so he could maybe fight in November he
doesn't want it though there's something
there's so much other [ __ ] going on yeah
yeah there's something there I think he
puts it on Colby as well yes
[Music]
no.not Woodley out why that's that's
weird for attaining to talk about this
now that's old that's this face winter
there's literally a thing of them saying
when like tomorrow it's gonna fight next
well I guess just [ __ ] I don't know
how kymaro's mind gets sound 70 I really
don't he looks as big as were shot Evans
he's so [ __ ] big never seemed air
until in person no it's [ __ ] enormous
yeah these guys do it yeah but they're
going to we'll figure it out yeah well
sure I'm Jesse dude how about this how
about uh Tribble gene can L fight this
weekend do you know that I didn't
there's no hype on it that's so weird
and that's strange I can't wait for that
fight don't tell me about the poor
Tagore so you can wait for that fight
poor didn't they fight yeah it's
Saturday bro I know but I haven't seen
it yet
goddamn did you see it what work show
time not to cover it yeah hmm
good fight downtown I think I I think
Porter makes everyone like that if
you're like that's not gonna keep
Thurman about like you don't really want
to fight Porter cuz he makes everyone
just it's a dog fight talking skills no
cuz there's style like you don't have
knockout power he just comes forward
it's like it's like it's hard alee good
and he's just it's exhausting to fight
him
no one wants to fight him it's just it's
just [ __ ] like it's not exciting like
you're not sell the fight you know he's
a phenomenal champion but it's just like
yeah just one of those matchups where
he'd much rather fight someone else we
can build the hype maybe get a knockout
I can I could knock Porter out
Canella triple G and you're right I
haven't heard much nothing very strange
but you just said you can't wait yeah I
want to see it I know but you can wait
yeah they really can wait yeah cuz I
think what happened it was Cannella test
and positive [ __ ] everything up could
we thought it was gonna be then and they
test positive for Hawkins you know also
apparently apparently canal has paid a
price with his Mexican fans for the
steroid thing
yeah well cuz they're like what the [ __ ]
man gone Mexico under the bus yes he's
like it's the Mexican meat I can't be
eating this Mexican meat they're like
the meats fine [ __ ] yeah
it's the steroids yeah our tacos are
fine yeah I've tried all of them tacos
right di watch this documentary on the
CrossFit Games and they're just bring up
some of the CrossFit women they're just
so [ __ ] huge and this guy this
Australian guy took third he was T
tested positive for steroids and the
rest of them with their traps a [ __ ]
about them and they were laude look look
and the people like this were like they
were like you know he's a cheater he's
dirty and it's stealing it's robbing
from those of us who are clean home like
really let's go there you go there you
go dude that's normal see that girl
right there yeah it's that's normal them
and Jessica them Jessica and Ross are
steroids nothing to take away from their
still phenomenal but come on
III don't be a hypocrite phenomena at
worship wait yeah yeah yeah I mean are
you [ __ ] joking me though it's
hilarious
who gives a [ __ ] like yeah of course
they do yeah until your until you're
going he's a piece of [ __ ] he's dirty
and you're like but you have giant abs
and what are you talkin to no one sees
it like it makes a zero news yeah cuz we
just assume it it's like the dough day
we have guys it's alright it's like them
the Olympia's like no one's like a well
I mean you know yeah it's the same thing
yeah well but they swear that it's their
queen
so does Olympia guess yeah you talk to
any of them they all I can't dude this
is protein and mistake dude yeah they're
yeah it's normal it's normal for a woman
have a chin like that yeah and you love
that no that's your style I'll tell you
I do lifestyle fitness going on earth to
me to eat she's so cute to me she got
the cutest face on the planet yeah fat
dick no she's very feminine fat dude to
the foot she's very feminine does she
have a 5 o'clock shudders she'd go fool
Beast would bring her up what's her name
- its Wu and CrossFit CrossFit 2017 top
female CrossFit athletes dude how do you
have time to look at this yeah
this oh you look at tier to me yeah
that's my girl so cute I mean get a
picture god
get the [ __ ] out no no your holy man no
just buy a hold on Julie that's it now
here's the prompt dude I want look at me
I want I can't accept you being I can't
look you in the eye year old gay man I
can't look you're going through a lot
no I'm now a midlife crisis Oh get me
another picture hey Gayle haslund oh let
me go accept this yeah I know it better
I don't care huh you know what okay look
her face she's very handsome
now listen another wife you know what if
you and chin looks [ __ ] I would not
care if that's what's going on hey lucky
me i watch chin so quiet on the weekends
and you're gone the weekends - I don't
care gentlemen all right that's it we're
[ __ ] each other no I do not care I
can explain what fine now we're on the
Rings what she's so cute all right now
don't do that don't be mean she's not
very pretty
no you're gaming right here no she's not
there's a downstream pretty handsome yes
she's very feminine these are bad
pictures yeah I'm sure all were terrible
I'm sure there's some light we can find
out there she's very very cute in some
ways yes she's very successful and
listen you like there she is you like a
manly woman there's no problem with this
I don't like Sundays over yeah you do
some guys like fat chicks you like I
like muscular girl like chicks with
dicks
I like muscular girls but that's a
little mad you have the worst taste in
women up chin that's how dear you
alright why I got a little carried away
are you looking at her in full CrossFit
mode I would love to look at your front
see how much time you waste looking up
girls I know you're talking about
lifting raise chicks with dicks number
one number one she looks at black guys
you'll get chicks with dicks is a weird
[ __ ] crown here cat yeah I forget
where I was going with this you and I
are the only normal ones in here rides
in the chicks with dicks Chin's in to
killing people and black dudes you're
under what's your style I like brown
dudes like Filipinos oh there's my thing
is your man Filipino yeah I also like
dudes are like quirky really weird
I like nerdy yeah like if you can make
me laugh and like watch Star Wars and
Game of Thrones I'm into it all right so
you like Filipino man who's not
they're beautiful people yep and you
like it if they're like a little door
like when I say dork it's a good term
like nerd run Hollywood yeah so you like
when they like know their [ __ ] on Game
of Thrones and then like the Netflix and
chill but also play video games on the
side and then on Sunday Mike I don't
know do nothing but a crossword puzzle
type in hot Filipino guys don't do that
Jim do it but that's just out your stout
cat you've I have you have you ever
dated outside the Filipino race I dated
one white guy I've dated two venomous
dudes and that's about it never a black
guy I didn't grow up with a lot of
exacta it was a lot of Asians and
Mexicans also I don't think black guys
really we're diggin me one I'll tell you
what's disturbing is this cat says that
she likes Filipino guys you fortune to
Google that so you could look at it cat
are looking at the screen hey could
there be any more sign George a man and
I don't give a [ __ ] laughing I don't
know okay my line is blowing it hot
Filipino guys and what's in this I know
Chen's gay he's like you ride away
really a tab you sure don't do black
alright speed time who's already in a
code but cat what was the difference
from those guys off what's the
difference from dating the white guy to
the Filipino yeah the white guy he was
cool um just had a asian fetish I felt
like it didn't really matter if it was
me or like another Asian aviation and
they just trying to get his rocks off an
asian fetish would be yeah that he just
likes asian girls yeah you know matter
if your energy it's like yes some people
are like that with it with black white
or also like with little people it's a
fetish oh they don't know if it's true
love
well I was with a little person who's a
comic and there's a hot hot girl we
talked about the only little person
who's a [ __ ] comic Brad Williams
Brian yeah hey detective well I don't
say his name but he don't know cuz a
small person who's a cop you know could
have been gonna she literally was so hot
and she pulled him in the bathroom yeah
told him the Banger yeah whether or not
he did I don't know but I was there very
cool
Brad I think told that story on the
podcast pretty sure he did yeah
interesting cat from another bus and so
now you're just sticking with the
Filipinos yep I don't like bro II dudes
either I'm the biggest bro I can handle
yeah little bro II yeah Brewery dudes
her little do you have brothers sisters
I have a younger sister and a baby
brother I just grew up with uh a lot of
dudes that's why that's fun dad
dad yeah mom brothers did was one baby
brother right I have a lot of cousins
yeah that's fair let's jump some current
events we're secant and current events
too cuz she's a little more up-to-date
on life than chin she gives us many good
current events yeah cuz Channel pull up
like chin has some negative ones yeah so
I said can't won't you help us out yeah
so there's a grocery store in Kuwait who
happened to have put googly eyes on all
their fish to make it seem like it's
fresher and a woman on her way home from
the grocery store saw the I fall off
while she was driving and realized what
was happening
do you think do you think they're naive
enough to put the eyes on things or are
they just doing it for the looks like
fresh fish I don't mind I don't know I
really do look cooler yeah but this shop
got shut down didn't I prefer my fish
with googly eyes don't even know if it's
illegal is it now hell decorating your
fish I think it's great I'm Pro googly
eye dude how about my boys at Showtime
were eating had a famous sushi place in
New York and a rat jumped on the table
no a giant mess when a rat jumped on the
table and everyone screamed ran out and
they're like do we need to pay our bill
and the rest our owners like just go
we'll take it from there sorry about
that yeah when I want to rat a subway
rat jumped on the table it jump just if
it wasn't afraid and running from
something or I was like dos tuna yeah
rainbow roll Wow a rat I know dude I
love rats I've been turned off sushi I
ordered sushi from one of my favorite
place and it came as kind of nasty I've
had it since it's been
since I made it month I've been turn off
sushi well she should you should be able
to not smell the fish if it smells I
know it's not this place is fishy
sweet sugar fish is delicious sugar fish
is amazing
I see so anti sugar fish around I felt
like it's North Korea they always tell
me I was gonna eat well let me start and
then I learn patience don't what's it
called Nozawa yeah when you just like
trust me it's delicious oh yeah it's the
best
yeah he's there who's the lice is warm
ones this time you guys went to chinny
ever been I got a lot you go a lot you
taught my omakase oh my gosh yeah see oh
my god did you eat sugar fish no not
sugar I go to a place in Newport Beach
Rob talked about sugar fizzle you said
do it go a lot to serve is just butter
public water you hungry yeah what else
we got cat a chin hey I was watching a
my 90-day fiance and they went to the I
think the Philippines or maybe it might
have been it's somewhere in Asia
pologize but on the street they have
these big eggs and then she was like ooh
you gotta try this just a black dude
from like New York she's like you gotta
try this so they crack open this [ __ ]
Jurassic Park Velociraptor egg she's
like this the biggest thing I've ever
seen
she goes sips green juice out of it and
then he goes what the [ __ ] and she takes
the cap off and there's a straight up
fetus bird with its [ __ ] feet tucked
up and he's like I'm not eating that
she's like with super disrespectful and
he ate it and he was so sick that's real
that's real uh it's very popular in the
Philippines as well as Vietnam and I
think Cambodia as well so he's hambo do
what is it what kind of what kind is it
it's a chicken egg the Filipino term for
is bullet but they're big yeah it's
basically a unborn fetus in an egg and
you boil it alive you drink the soup in
it it tastes like broth and then you
pour again oh that's it that's it oh
this is what I was talking about when I
said jungle Asian vs. fancy Asian boils
alright I don't I
had it before I've never ate the bird I
only eat the yolk and drink the like a
little broth inside you get the bird do
they eat that yeah I mean you ate that
Jun yeah son of a-- I feel bad for
little birdies cute they do they boil
them alive in there yeah what's the
difference between this and eating
soft-shell crab probably nothing but
soft-shell crab now I just feel bad for
the little cute chicken let them let
them at least grow up and then kill and
it's live faithful okay give him give
him at least chop his beak off and put
him in a cage so I can't move even three
months of life in a cage on a factory
for at least the outside and hot sauce
if you're gonna do this but you've ate
this a lot
not often listen man like when I watch
The Fear Factor any of those game shows
and eat weird stuff the physical stuff I
would dominate out [ __ ] on most people
when it comes this I'm telling you I do
not have the mental strength to eat that
it's always said job I will give you a
million dollars and put those gold rims
on your Porsche that you want all you
got to do is suck this egg I could not
do all you have to do is drink horse
semen or horse urine do you know that
that was one of the things I know that's
what doesn't cancel you know what valid
and I understand that's when you jump
the shark if you're gonna drink horse
semen then do the bit but did I think
horse semen in that wrinkle you know I'd
rather I'd rather suck off mr. hands and
eat that me I like that I'll need a
pip-boy old baby chicken [ __ ] horse
semen or horse urine horse journeys
might of course you're an all day over
horse semen
I'll take horse urine all look at that's
disgusting I can't believe you guys do
that every now you only brain I'm great
tongue never I won't eat that was
delicious
[ __ ] peanut gallery over I know man
Korean BBQ and in tacos that's like some
of the best meat no disgusting hey have
you guys I got one for you guys like be
all exotic you ever had Rocky Mountain
Oysters [ __ ] y'all then that's what I
thought yeah balls they're they're coke
balls and or nobody knows
their ball falls but their hope also to
you Rocky Mountain Oysters hump from the
Rocky Mountains they take a [ __ ] fat
ass testicle some nuts from bull they
roll them out and then they deep-frying
oh we have bull testicle and fall no
don't try jumping on this bull I was
eating I'm not trying to get like that
is that the dick that's the books a
testicle no that's it there you go those
are the testicles I was eating I was
[ __ ] eating all these little balls
Lebanese restaurant I was eating these
little balls [ __ ] and they were so cool
I should say they were coated in yogurt
and lemon I was eating the [ __ ] I go
what are these how did I get the meat to
be this Rhino guy goes and I'm wolfram
down up just whoopee world war from bad
guys those are go balls I can't do this
it was so [ __ ] dude I you know I
can't heal anymore at sushi restaurant
you know what I'll pass on II often I
think that's all squishy uh pass on you
know I don't like and I and I they
served me on her utter meat auger me in
Mexico to suck on another of a cow yeah
soft I want to squeeze one I never I
just wanna scream multicast I told
somebody I milked the cow one time so he
goes you lied somebody goes you ever
milk count and I didn't even I just went
yeah and then and then I was like bond
just slide and I lied because I didn't
want to look like a [ __ ] yeah and then
they're talking you know when you pull
down I'm not sure yeah and then I was
like I'm just gonna let this license I
saw I lied I had this weird idea when I
was a kid what I do is what I always
thought I want to do on a farm I we saw
a bunch of cousing
Colorado but I'd put Hershey's chocolate
at the at the bottom of that thing in
this coke and shake it up and drink the
chocolate milk that's my vision yeah
yeah it's not a bad thing
because it's not bad ideas right raw raw
whole warm milk is kind of done with the
chocolate and it's very creamy and then
once in a nice and friendly count just
squid squeeze it's no going yeah I'll
get you boss I get you raw cow's no no
whoa whoa I don't like [ __ ] milk bro
I told you I have a fetish on a squeezes
tit and then you want chocolate milk and
then drink it in front of my squishes
nose going yeah
yes so you want the feeling you want
that sensation of feeling that that's
soft feeling on your hands or noses well
you get that chocolate velvety feeling
in your mouth yeah that's a good feel
yes you can do that to my dick if you
want you feel like this yeah yeah you
can drink chocolate milk ooh yeah
you're nice Wow you're not soft like a
gal bro my dick when it's off this no
but there's nothing gay about it with
the cow with you it's all okay just
guard this coat guard this take my the
head of my dog and go like that and I'll
go like this oh no you're too skinny bro
oh geez skinny well you close your eyes
and just feel that chocolate milk go
down your throat no I need the warm milk
well straight from the cows the utters
okay I would like to go to a farm I had
a girlfriend look at me and she goes I
want to take she goes you know what I
want to do to you
and she was not funny at all and I go
what she goes I want to pierce your
taint little I want to put up I want to
put a hook there and I want to attach it
to a leash and walk your oh my god I
went god damn it you're weird Jesus I
laughed hard at that hurt what else you
got gin or I got a piss out of my huge
dick but you what do you want to pee or
you wants to do this I want to hear this
okay well Nicki Minaj and cardi B got in
a fight at a show during in New York
Fashion Week I was ok so apparently
Nicki Minaj said that cardi B was a bad
mother and started talking [ __ ] about
her baby
Mr D B saw her at the party try to get
in a fight but Nicki's entourage her
bodyguard typically yeah someone someone
from that security her entourage punched
cardi B who's a 25 year old female and
she looked gift she has this knot on the
side of her head look at this oh my god
this is New York Fashion Week so you
know how high society huge not ya know
people are speculating right now that
it's either Nikki got able to punch her
nose because fine Nikki walked down and
she had script like her knuckles were
scraped and that but other people are
speculating that it's probably from when
the bodyguards have you seen the video
just yeah yeah it wasn't on the body but
this all stems from two
cardi B says Nicki Minaj for the longest
would tell other artists cardi B's way
big and Nicki right now she's like the
hottest thing in the street band so
Nicki Minaj wouldn't let up would tell
other artists if you work with cardi B
I'm never gonna work with you again
so she like was blackballed I was kind
of an [ __ ] yeah human Asha is
actually kind of notorious for this now
judges she did this to another famous
artist named Remy Ma and after I mean ma
talked about it a lot of other people
came out and started saying that's why
they don't like Nicki and it's
specifically female rappers and then so
once that gets out right people find out
you're a complete dick and I've heard
this for the longest I worked with a
company that worked with Nicki and I
said who's the worst you I worked with
it said Nicki by far like a nightmare to
deal with the worst Devo you've ever
seen why well once I get the [ __ ] now
she had to cancel her US tour because
ticket sales weren't going that's what
happens to nobody around some I know
people go oh your dick we're out man
that's what happens if you're an [ __ ]
and they've done actual Studies on this
Adam grant is done like who's a economic
behavioral economics professor at I
think that's what he does it I started a
Celina coordinate they at the number one
business for people who treat other
people like that in business even in
politics or anywhere you get away with
it for a little while pretty soon what
happens is people start conspiring
against you when you're an [ __ ] like
that you get found out especially
because she's an [ __ ] because she's
jealous
Shekhar DB's the rankest thing and she's
a female rapper and it's a terrible man
everyone loves cardi B she's so happy
go-lucky friendly like she's such a you
know brags a riches story Nicki Minaj
sucks a lot of people actually love Nick
I'm not Nicki cardi even more after this
came out because people are saying at
least she she's real yes she's real
that's about it but that's what cardi B
said to she goes in and she did a whole
Instagram thing and she goes you know
Nicki Minaj talks all this [ __ ] and then
when I tried to address it you know
she's just all for show yeah kind of
cool cardi B also just released a
lipstick with Tom Ford yesterday and it
sold out of course she's shoot right
after this happened love it did you try
to be like Brian you have piss out of
your weird spotted dick yep alright go
ahead dude pee on that 50 year old how's
that prostate gone like an old right oh
it doesn't look great
oh it's not bad what else she got Jam
and cat so Mac Miller died the other day
from an apparent overdose do you hear
about this I don't know who he is I
heard about it
he's a rapper oh god he's one of my
favorites - really this one bump me up
26 he's always pretty like go lucky he
had a show on MTV
it's like Mac Miller and friends or
forget what it is the Mack life it was
hilarious yeah and it's really sad
because people are speculating that
there were that this could have been
prevented because he got in a car
accident of like a month or two ago he
crashed his g-wagen into a car because
paparazzi were following him yeah and so
him and his friends left the car and
left one of their friends behind to take
care of business with the cops when they
came yeah they took off in another car
and went back home and people were
speculating that it was probably him
depressed over his breakup with Ariana
Grande yeah and now people basically
well in Ariana's page and just bombarded
her with comments like you're the reason
why he died first of all he's always had
product from what I read he broke up
with him because he I don't probably go
he's been wrestling she was like man I
tried helping him he's just so bad yeah
they separated because they broke up
with yeah as somebody did that
experience separate because yeah he's a
drug addict I can't help you you get out
of there unless you're you know you
can't you not gonna fix it it's such a
bummer man how many young people are
dying from [ __ ] drugs it's so many
these days Mike had the guy I was
telling you about the caddy his best
friend over near his died of a drug
dude this with Matt Miller two out there
what bums you out is they people are
posting videos him as a kid God that
makes me sad when I was from one of his
music the shomers a kid rapping and like
just all outgoing and like just a good
dude alright he was funny yeah hilarious
rob dyrdek was like he's the finest
person I know it was no one has a bad
thing to say about him
what a bummer man what a bummer I'm 26
that's so young that stuff just dropped
an album like killing him and that's
really sad too because when
album came out it was the same day
astral world came out Travis Scott's
really popular album and a lot of people
were making fun of Mac Miller releasing
an album on the same day saying [ __ ]
like did y'all hear some yeah that's why
did he release it this day he knows no
one's gonna listen to yours over and
then this happens and now everybody is
saying that they miss him
it says Mac Miller's home was clean
before the investigation whoa
that's similar in the Demi Lovato cakes
to Mac Miller's home script clean of all
drugs prior than 9-1-1 call so they knew
he was dead and then they just want to
clean everything up so it doesn't
because he's dead right so they don't
wanna make it look worse yeah
Demi Lovato - but least I mean she's
alive but thankfully she's life [ __ ] man
it's that [ __ ] gets encrypted corn to
TMZ when police arrived they found only
a small trace of white powder based on
Mary's witness other evidence in Vienne
should I believe some removed other
drugs from no she um yeah no [ __ ] Wow
I'll talk to dr. Troy I performed
terminologies that cause of death
meanwhile you're gonna ground eight
Jesus Christ man that's such a [ __ ]
shame good picture it was a her feet
gentle a gentle soul it looks like yeah
I wouldn't bum me out man what else you
got Jim Owens he said part of the reason
why he was at Trader Joe's in the first
place was because the residual checks he
would get from Cosby The Cosby Show
would stop coming in after that scandal
real face outrageous candle stuff oh it
was on all the time then once Cosby got
busted for all those rape allegations
networks yanked it mmm damn say do get a
job at Trader Joe's nothing wrong with
Trader Joe's but he put yes it impacted
me financially at the time the show was
pulled that did make a difference in our
income that was one of our elements that
led to my kin took in a place where I
said to myself I have to do something I
was thinking what can I do and that's
end up being Trader Joe's which is
actually a wonderful situation for me in
many ways nothing wrong with that
but now he is like he got a gig right he
had a job a lot of offers and Tyler
Perry is offering him a movie role
that's got brought up last night good
even jut out I was like I'll put you in
movies right now yeah got hooked up
that's great Nicki Minaj actually went
on her radio state no radio show Queen
and said that she donated twenty five
thousand to him well she that's her
publicist saying hey yeah I'm not
looking shucks
you look like an ass but also I'm sorry
there's way more people out there
struggling financially and in life than
this guy why are we wait I'm sorry we're
feeling sorry for the I'm sure he's a
great guy I'm sorry for him why it's
because the photo came out and initially
when it came out a lot of people were on
online just making fun of making fun of
him basically yeah saying that he went
from being on The Cosby Show to bagging
groceries but you said that instantly
afterwards there were a lot of people
who came out and supported him saying
that he was making an honest living
there's nothing wrong with this and he
got a lot of support I'm so hard time
why are people donating money to him
he's not homeless
I know I know people weigh less it's
like anything else he looked like a
dignified guy working he had a stain
sure they're like maybe struggling we'll
give money yeah I did give money I gave
$50 to Mary Ann from Gilligan's Island
she lost her house she's 79 she had a
knee injury place with no money and she
did her friend said do ran a GoFundMe
page she goes she has no money and she's
79 she's been an actress a long time and
I was like I read the article and I was
like I'm giving her 50 bucks $50 Brian
yeah that's so sad well but I mean she
raised like a lot see how much she's
raised so far I mean I don't want to get
over I don't want to go over this well
no don't do anything
I'm just adding my yeah I get to give
too much I like what the [ __ ]
no it adds to you know no not ginger to
Mary Ann dawn wells dawn wells yeah and
don't Wells
I've never done that before but I just
felt so bad I read and I was like I want
to give her some money yes I would a
family can only
hollers up an old woman should not lose
their house whoa
how much did you get hundred thirty fish
well she need because she knew by God
so she needed 200 grand she was in major
debt no it says there's 180,000 and she
had already left and she'd already left
her she'd already lost all her her house
as an old lady
that's why did she learn a house she
didn't have money she went into debt she
got injured and she did you know I mean
look when you're an actor and you're so
so sag pension is nothing you're not
making money you know I don't know money
somebody I know too many other people
have no money I can't stand $50 let's I
know I was like what do I give - I give
hundred I'm 50 yeah well you know
there's my boy Todd stashwick gave money
hold on go down
that's my good friend yes Todd 20 bucks
$20 it adds up it adds on well you know
when I donate to the Vegas shootings I
donate $3,000 Saphir did you yeah so
what's a [ __ ] if I had to go fun with it
as all people went $5 I'd respond Mike
keep your money but it adds up I love
them money money hey Todd 20 yards do
better man it adds up it's just a
gesture I'm helping out I give a lot of
money to charity believe me yeah
whatever a lot we gave this poorly
dollars you have to pick and choose
little areas yes she needs a hundred
ninety-eight penalties to the IRS yeah
yeah I think I'll be up on I do know I
don't like putting my name I would never
I do it anonymously we just told 50 yeah
they said there was up space so I put my
name I think mm ain't put on all of us
so you put anything that's hilarious
what a very clear look at this what
actors yeah 82
dude how about I saw thing where she
[ __ ] hated what did you do in the
movie Boogie Nights
you regretted during the movie but you
know it's
he fought his agents on it here's my
kind of inspired his agents after that
because he's a concern he's great in
that movie great amazing great act about
one of the best small-time yeah dude
remember when he smacked the media do
you remember when he smacked the [ __ ]
camera guy interviewing him uh this is
like five ten years ago he's got a red
carpet and this guy was interviewing
like said the wrong name or movie is
what he taught my by him and the guys
like huh saw that you never seen Bert
round slap the [ __ ] out of the red media
yeah
god I'd love to see him do this to you
chin I don't know man once the Burt
Reynolds slap Jim [ __ ] he was he got
into trouble to eat in the 70s he that
he didn't work fundamentals [ __ ] all
the women holder when he was in 71 in
the 70s when it tidy up with young girls
working
he played football to play along you
should know but uh but he he ended up
getting in some trouble I guess for what
buoyed up he didn't he didn't work for a
while because he became too difficult
yeah I mean he was keep going though
bring him down to he looked like I he
looked like Brando I mean look at him
yeah that's Brando there is it really
yeah he looks a lot like don't go to the
list of the movies he did what's his
biggest movie think Smokey and the
Bandit Sharky's machine amazing movie
these were all do I be among the Longest
Yard was probably his biggest movie I
think now he was in crowd
are you talking about the old blood do
go fasters yard run the best movies you
know just about the new what not the old
one sailors know the old one when he's
starting it he was in crime yeah yeah
smoking in the band man it was a serious
that was as big as it Oh what was the
football movie he was then first into
muff no no no
the football movies had robert long as
yard no there's another 1000 Roughnecks
um he was the coach all dogs here to
have in great move I mean he was so cop
in a house sharky's machine you got a
see that's cheap going dude I'm trying
to think why he was so big for me some
as a kid so many movies I guess he was
an all dogs go to heaven for me holy
[ __ ] he was in a lot of movies yeah yeah
I mean he was blood he died of remember
deliverance what Zach deliverance I
would say he was amazing in heart attack
huh yeah
deliverance is great that's a good run
82 he had a good life yeah I just from
there it's all downhill in there yeah a
vain man though where that to pay
forever Sam I tell I'm thinking to a
movie where the cover is while white and
green has a football the mohawk on it
type in roughly I myself was football
yeah I'm thinking of a dip roughneck and
there was a girl a hot girl I think was
Kathy Ireland was the kicker in it go to
images no that's - I'm 14
dude that's not it Kathy up to putting
Kathy Ireland football about holding mow
do you know it Kathy Arlen oh yeah yeah
that's it what movie is that necessary
please type that inch in that's my
[ __ ] movie well this just one
referring to I started as a kid do you
remember this movie yeah look at the
football yeah I used to have that movie
as a kid who was all in it don't
Reynolds not in that movie dude not
Bert's not in it Sinbad is though man no
I'm saying bro give it up Brown [ __ ]
knocking pounds for Necessary Roughness
dog don't ruin everything here necessary
ruff
yeah Oh Kathy Ireland Watson bass yet
jason bateman a young and Rob Schneider
yeah
that's it my boy my boy from the program
who did all the steroids
evander holyfield dude classic Jerry
Rice guy who looks like Bareilles but
what else we got shout out to Burt
Reynolds one of the greats man yeah I
did
how great was that dude how about it was
I was in a taxi in New York and you have
the they have the news on the taxis
I'm staring and I didn't I knew you know
I must gonna be on Rogen but I don't
know I was just doing I didn't see the
internet or anything and I'm gone I see
you and I'm most smoking like that looks
like [ __ ] Rogan student I see the
ticket the bomb like holy [ __ ] nurse
says Elon Musk visits podcaster smokes
weed and I'm like whacked off [ __ ] and
then started showing he's he get a lot
of heat for that he did but did you see
him smoke it it looked like he just
literally put put in his mouth and then
public you didn't his stock went down
and two employees quit right so there's
big ramifications from it here it is
this will happen afterwards says
Thursday musk appeared on the comedian
Joe Rogan's pockets were two-hour
conversation which he smoked what Rogen
said was marijuana and drank whiskey no
one acknowledges the whiskey it's wears
on Friday two of Tesla's top executive
resigned the US Air Force which has
multiple contracts with mus SpaceX
reportedly began looking to must
marijuana use because it's prohibited
from some for someone with government
security clearance the Air Force denied
there's an investigation said it needs
to determine the facts an appropriate
process to handle and by the way also
all those Air Force guys are Rogan fans
yeah and also hit the stock is down not
because Elon Musk smokes weed the stock
is down for a lot yeah yes that's the
SharePoint price on Friday felt almost
its lowest point for the year I'm sure
that didn't help them be probably
there's a number of factors that
definitely caused some of it but sure
holders have stayed engaged they Dave
they get they don't get that government
bailout that car costs a lot more to
make so I bought that car for probably
thirty grand less than what it would
cost but because of government subsidies
I was able to get that car for at least
thirty grand less so the big question is
when if they don't get that government
by a bailout now what you know ken I
think it's I think some work yeah I
think overall though it's hilarious that
Elon Musk was on Rogen smoking weed did
you all podcast I watched all of it
what'd you think of it I didn't I saw I
only saw like anything I think it might
be Roland's most watched part by far but
I mean at least from where where was
when it started yeah now most what if
I'm the fastest podcasts that were done
knew it was great the whole thing was
gonna talk about AI simulation yeah man
you freaked out hey I scare you iPod
talk is [ __ ] scary the way he says it
to the way he looks around when he's
saying it you know what's interesting
did you ask what question he's very
calculated guy right yeah any goes
questions requests long time as you
question so are you are you afraid of
arrow a I and he goes I wouldn't say
afraid if you no longer polonaise I was
like I was a damn he's really well
thought out here yeah he thinks before
he speaks smart dude I'm like me what
else you got gin I think it's amazing
indeed I liked him a lot to you after
that so Twitter permanently Bend Alex
Jones and is in fours handle to hugs
Jones by the way I just want to say is
seven years younger than me it's got
some weathered that's impossible because
he's got he's got this law firm that's
no joke and they're not gonna settle
they're gonna sue him and bring it all
the way and he could lose a lot of money
I'm scared of a bad guy in here yeah
yes he is I think and damn Facebook and
YouTube kick Jones the primary accounts
off I mean that's three making money
he's also very aware that the Sandy Hook
thing is real but he knows that if he
goes bad on it his 525 although when he
was getting sued
know when he got sued he goes you I do
it for entertainment you think I really
believe it like I said
like well they they I had him at what
can you do Jen I'm not a fan what else
you got
I'm not finished all right so this is
another bad one but it's pretty popular
right now the story this Dallas police
officer who she was going to her
apartment after work okay and this so
she was a off-duty but she still had her
uniform on
she was Wonder apartment after work
around 10:00 something p.m. and then she
really eats she didn't know at the time
but she walked into someone else's
apartment on accident on accident and
then killed the guy that was in there
because she thought someone's breaking
her home yes she's crazy that's such a
crazy thing that's such a bummer how did
she get into the apartment
I don't you try unlock maybe so they
even showed like I saw some video of it
you can't get in there's like a key and
it has to go green or red so it might
have been open or something maybe was
not open and she was like what the [ __ ]
and thought it was their house have you
guys ever walked into the wrong pie half
I have you ever watched a wrong a pyro
woman this poor woman and that poor guy
both of them I mean okay that's this is
where it's weird though like how do you
how do you get to a point where shooting
someone well she's a woman there's a
dude in her house in her but when you
watch what are you doing in my apartment
the guy unless the guy's running after
and trying but also don't you realize
when you walk in that that's not all
your [ __ ] like I recognize right away
like I've walked in when I was in
college Drock in the wrong dorm right
we're like oh [ __ ] I've walked in the
women's bathroom on accident I've done
that I watched em like me too wow this
book oh but how did she not like who
knows that's why there's an
investigation but the guy was a
churchgoer beloved by the community
happened to be a black guy it's a
disaster [ __ ] it's just a nightmare
human flaw yeah it's a nightmare not
good for it it's one of those no ways
and things right it's like it's though
it's a bride who's getting her picture
taken and falls off the back of the
horse and snaps or [ __ ] that or it's
the bride's getting her picture taken in
water in the Bahamas I disagree yeah and
a stingray that that's the that's what
they think
hooked onto her heard that story I
remember say between her [ __ ]
Achilles well no she but first of all to
this give stingray a little credit she
stepped on his tail she stepped on his
tail he was like
I think it just caught her in the ankle
and the thing ran away terrified can you
imagine in your life you're like babe
after this week yeah I mean there's
weird [ __ ] that happens your child gets
eaten by an alligator
they're terrible things that happen the
worlds of bad accidents they also found
out that this girl shot someone
previously like years ago but when they
looked into the investigation of that
the guy had two years in prison
afterwards because the guy try to steal
the taser gun from her this is just
about this is just human flawed they
both she made a mistake
that's what they're saying what do you
do with this dumb what do you put her in
prison no you just say they have to do
the investigation but I the she wasn't
charged for murder she was charged for
manslaughter we have to leave we have to
leave space for human error and crazy
[ __ ] that happens you know it's a bummer
what else yet Jen it is a bummer
is there anything else you want to pull
up Kat do you know what happens if
you're texting and you kill somebody
yeah you're in deep [ __ ] want to talk
about that Machine Gun Kelly it goes
down a deep rabbit hole for Brian he
probably won't know who these guys are
I know one more one more then how about
this this PhD doctor is getting ripped
on Twitter because she put a message out
to Cantus airlines getting upset that
they didn't call her doctor they called
her Miss a [ __ ] has a ego problem hold
on
this is what she wrote Hey Qantas my
name is dr. O'Dwyer do not look at my
ticket says dr. Dwyer do not look at my
ticket look at me look back at my ticket
decided to type on call me miss O'Dwyer
I did not spend eight years at universe
to be called myths [ __ ] so obviously
everyone attacked her after that and
she's like no I'm just sticking up for
women uh no you're not Wow Wow she
probably got bombarded and I was I'm
assuming she's kind of [ __ ] herself as
a doctor well she has her own private
driveway but
still so that's what she wrote
afterwards coughing so much flak for
this tweet this is not about my ego yeah
it is it was a baja that's all it is
highlighting one of a thousand instances
of sexism that women encounter every day
it's not about the title it's about the
fact that this wouldn't have happened if
I was a man now boy oh so if you're a
man I think they've called you dr.
O'Dwyer no I'm sure they don't give a
[ __ ] you're a doctor they're trying to
load the plane you [ __ ] yeah anyways
it's complete eagle she sounds like an
a-hole
she'll hustle around and ladies and like
yeah sorry that's we live in a sexist
world okay whatever you did get your
doctorate so how sexist can it be
whatever don't fly that airline dumbass
we'd be the worst we'd be the worst
judges like yeah get out if I was
customer service like wide shut the [ __ ]
up man don't fly the airline stupid ass
uh-huh get a round-faced get off my
plane your frisbees face get off to [ __ ]
up my part get a face like a watermelon
get off the plane frisbee face Brennan
she's in podcast hey listen dr.
cantaloupe face you get off my plane
come on hey round kid face get off my
plane round kids pick somebody space
didn't get out of the fourth grade so
the fourth grader face
hey kid face get off the plane doctor
kid face get the [ __ ] off my plane
doctor kid that's really I'm appalled is
that it great grand wonderful well dude
that's it we're doing some traveling
next week I you'll hold down the fort
cuz you're gone yeah I have one find the
kid next week I'll find a co-host this
Thursday I'm in Vancouver I think it's
sold out we can check tickets Vancouver
t fat K calm and then next week I'm in
Chicago Schaumburg improv Thursday
Friday Saturday and then the week after
that I'm at the parlor live in Bellevue
Washington Seattle
tickets at epoch a calm be you know what
I'll just be in New York I'm missing the
road are you all ready but you know I'm
gonna be busy you're surprised
the Goldbergs and i go in school so I'm
busy acting it could be much worse
correct man but all right
well we'll see you guys around town
thanks for listening
till next time this is the fine kid
we're out